la chronique culture du mercredi aurélia
dans un instant nous verrons que l'on
peut soutenir la recherche sur la
sclérose en plaques en dansant
exactement dans le cadre de rencontres
chorégraphiques et pour cela nous
recevons donc pour nous en parler ce
soir sandrine ferrand bonsoir donc vous
êtes directrice artistique de
l'événement les tendances c'est la
deuxième édition qui a lieu donc cette
année à l'institut marcel rivière à la
verrière également ce soir pour en
parler bonsoir donc marie-aude henrich
donc vous vous avez plutôt géré la
partie communication tout de cet
événement donc événement donc en effet
ce sont des rencontres chorégraphiques
dont les fous fils aideront à financer
en tout cas l'unisep donc qui est donc
une association qui lutte contre la
sclérose en plaques donc nous en
reparlerons tout à l'heure mais dans un
premier temps pour bien comprendre
rencontres chorégraphiques alors de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit d'un spectacle de danse qui va
durer deux heures qui va être présentée
par 70 danseurs professionnels et
amateurs aux univers à la fois très
différents et complémentaires à mon sens
et là on essaye que ce soit un beau
spectacle
tout le monde se prépare activement la
répète et oui puisque actuellement ce
sont donc les répétitions en effet à
leur ordre
ce sont des correct ce sont des
chorégraphies libre où il ya un fil
conducteur les différentes troupes et
écoles de danse présente absolument ce
qu'il désire
après j'ai quand même je me suis quand
même tourner vers des artistes dont le
travail me touche bien sûr mais dans le
travail et surtout
la bhl est reconnue d'accord privilégier
la qualité hockey est donc là ce son lit
de l'idée en fait un globalement c'est
de pouvoir faire rencontrer différents
disciplines de danse également et c'est
ça donc on peut trouver il y aura la
danse classique par exemple avec par
exemple une danseuse de la compagnie
nathalie lui qui vient présenter une
variation de la bayadère donc on
pourrait penser des danses en opposition
mais finalement qui sont complémentaires
et qui vont permettre au public
d'accueillir ces différents styles et
peut-être même d'aller voir des
bateliers emmené wii vers vers une
discipline vers laquelle il serait
peut-être pas allé spontanément d'accord
d'accord et donc là cette première
objectif je dirais de ces rencontres
chorégraphiques parce qu'il ya un second
objectif qui cette fois ci et donc les
fonds récoltés iront en faveur de
l'unicef alors je veux pourquoi ils
tiennent déjà alors l'unisep donc c'est
une c'est l'association qui regroupe qui
fédère plusieurs associations de par
rapport à la sclérose en plaques sur la
recherche sur l'aide aux familles l'aide
aux malades etc et donc l'unisep
regroupe regroupe tout c'est toutes ces
associations là et en fait on a choisi
cette association parce que on a dans
nos entourages respectifs des personnes
qui sont atteintes par cette maladie
donc de fait ça nous a semblé assez
naturel d'aller vers cette association
la rue d'accord et l'année dernière 1 il
ya deux ans par don puisque c'est un
événement triste et d'une 7e biennale
voilà exactement dont vous aviez pu
récolter au combien de 2 dont on était
environ
800 euros c'est ça bon d'accord donc on
souhaite cette année aux mots quand
exactement
je reviens juste sur la partie
chorégraphique parce que c'est important
je trouve de pouvoir mélanger ces
univers de danse
est-ce que vous il ya un message
particulier où ces deux souhaitiez
véhiculée par rapport à la au
différentes disciplines exactement
entrée en tant que vous-même
professionnel vous êtes professeur
correctement l'idée c'était aussi de
décloisonner un peu les disciplines qui
sont parfois je trouve trop représenter
chacune individuellement et on ne va pas
forcément aller voir un battle de hip
hop ou un grand ballet classique en
entier et là il y aura des des hip
hopeurs et des ballerines réunis sur le
même plateau
le mariage se fait facilement justement
entre ces deux univers
le oui bizarrement oui parce que on se
rend compte justement les mettant côte à
côte qui sont très complémentaires et qu
ils s'influencent mutuellement ils ont
beaucoup de choses en commun
contrairement aux pratiques et les
petites de danse mais bien sûr il ya
beaucoup de danseurs qui pratique
différents types de danses et pas que de
moi même d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
pratiqué du classique du jazz
contemporain j'ai même fait un peu de
hip hop les beaucoup de danseurs sont
pluridisciplinaires elle en tant
qu'artiste cantons pratiquent ces
différentes dont justement dans a
forcément une qu'on préfère en tout cas
on s'exprime différemment en fonction de
la danse aussi
oui l'expression la technique en fait
apporte à le fait d'avoir plusieurs
directives techniques nous force
finalement à trouver notre propre
langage voilà vous préférez quel type
alors venant placer plus beau clin
j'aime tout autant que ces deux là
dedans c'est que c'est du geste et que
ça raconte une histoire derrière c'est
ça c'est ça la danse et comment le
public est accueilli il ya deux ans du
pouce cet événement qui est un peu
particulier est-ce-qu'il quels ont été
leurs retours justement sur cette
diversité
ben justement ils ont beaucoup apprécié
cette diversité parce que par exemple
une personne qui me dit je ne serais
jamais allé
opéra paris voire gisèle et elle l a
beaucoup apprécié voir une danseuse
magnifique qui n' a pas fait tout le
ballet giselle mais qui avait fait une
très belle variation par exemple les
salles et ça leur donne envie d'aller
voir ailleurs ça c'est une des réussites
aussi des rencontres
parce qu'il faut ramener donc vous avez
réussi donc à fédérer une dizaine de
compagnies ou d'écoles de danse autour
de ce projet dont certaines ont fait
partie de l'événement il ya deux ans
mais on retrouve des danseurs qui
étaient déjà là qu'il y avait beaucoup
enthousiasmer le public il ya des petits
nouveaux et des nouveaux ou alors pour
les dates donc c'est le 13 avril donc
samedi dans quinze jours globalement
donc un institut au théâtre de
l'institut marcel rivière à la verrière
donc on a un petit bandeau qui s'est
affichée avec tout
toutes les coordonnées les numéros
surtout pour préserver
oui surtout faux avis voilà sachant que
pour appeler aussi peut-être le tarif
c'est 12 euros ces douze euros un tarif
unique rue voilà donc tout est dit donc
on vous souhaite un très bon spectacle
si on poursuit cette page culture à
présent par pour bo larsen et oui donc à
l'occasion du 4e festival de
marionnettes dont qui a lieu à bois
d'arcy chaque année et cette année donc
un univers à nouveau très poétique très
magique
nous allons rencontrer ses marionnettes
regarder une image poésie féerie
imaginaire voilà en quelques mots
l'univers magique et marionnettes
proposé par la grange de la tramblais
jusqu'au 7 avril
à l'initiative de la ville de bois
d'arcy le 4e festival de marionnettes
est l'occasion pour petits et grands de
découvrir des techniques de manipulation
original une programmation qui se veut
diversifiée parce que l'art de la
marionnette déjà c'est un art qui n'est
pas spécifique à un style de
marionnettes dans le monde entier des
traditions différentes avec des
manipulations différentes soirées
théâtre le fameux guignol avec les
manettes à genk scène a été filmée comme
un être sur table sa marque se développe
beaucoup parce qu'au delà de la mallette
jusqu'à l'objet voilà donc on crée
l'imaginer au niveau 2 des gens du
public et autant public jeune public que
à des théâtres et opéras objets comédie
musicale autant de genre présentée au
festival entre diversité des techniques
et diversité des cultures
les marionnettes invite au voyage les
gens pensent souvent que les
marionnettes sont des marionnettes à
fils ou éventuellement à main alors
qu'en fait si la quantité de techniques
et si en plus de ça on fait un petit peu
le tour du monde
ce qu'on propose là c'est la diversité
qui devient intéressant diversité des
techniques les diversités aussi des
cultures c'est le voyage
je ne sais plus tard la foi véritable
spectacle vivant les marionnettes
transmettent toutes sortes d'émotions
qui font le bonheur du public
ça rappelle l'enfance à la fois c'est
pour les petits pour les grands parce
qu'on fait passer des messages
extraordinaire à travers les
marionnettes les deux prochains
spectacles à voir en famille auront lieu
samedi 6 et dimanche 7 avril